d'accord et les RPG bien au-dessus, nous ferions mieux de
faire attention, vous ne voulez pas que les meilleures
choses de votre vie arrivent à votre
alter ego en ce moment mon alter ego est sur un
hélicoptère sur le point de mourir seulement l'oie
désolé mademoiselle Lowenthal je publierai votre
livre c'était juste si vrai non-fiction
vrais mémoires d'un
assassin international tu as dit que tu ne changerais pas un
mot je n'ai pas Brandon aussi les gens
circulation homme peut-être qu'ils font peut-être qu'ils
font tout le truc de l'assassin c'est
BS bien je pourrais vous dire mais  alors je
devrais te trancher la gorge et te regarder
saigner
je ne l'ai pas fait tu vas tuer le
président je te promets que tu t'es
trompé de gars
quel vrai assassin écrire un livre
sur le fait d'être un assassin c'est plus que
stupide je '  Je vais te sortir de là ou
est-ce tellement stupide que c'est génial, il
pourrait en fait être la vraie affaire,
eh bien, n'y regarde pas, je t'imaginais
un peu tu sais plus longtemps tu n'es
pas le fantôme oh peut-être que je suis le  fantôme
maintenant tu dois te sortir d'ici
mission z  une mission ce n'est pas ennuyeux le
fantôme ne s'en va pas simplement
[Musique]
vous